you can [ __ ] off I'm not getting in that
thing let's take a few years before I'm
willing to climb into that sucker
but so the other problem with
conspiracies just get back that for a
moment is the problem of anomalies what
do you do with anomalies this is true in
all science no theory explains every
single thing that's out there that we
want to study there's always going to be
some like quirky thing that the main
theory here that explains all these
things here it doesn't account for that
mm-hmm okay what did we do with that my
joke is you assign it to a grad student
they've let them figure it out but what
what outsiders mistake is that well my
theory explains this little anomaly so
therefore it should replace this theory
and so people like Neal and Sean Carroll
lawrence krauss Michio Kaku has like two
web pages one he has a link on his web
page if you have an alternative theory
of physics go to this page so they go
there and it has your theory has to
explain all of these things over here
that our theory currently explains and
your whatever your said anomaly is and
of course they can't so it's not that
scientists are dogmatically
closed-minded to the anomalies it's that
we can't explain everything and you
don't have to do anything with that just
just leave it there maybe eventually
they'll pile up and there'll be a new
theory like with Einstein's relativity
okay there's enough anomalies here like
the orbit of mercury and a few other
things and so we have to modify
Newtonian physics a little bit okay that
happens but for the most part like and
so conspiracies are filled with these
things like the moment something big
happens you go back and okay but there's
this weird thing here how do you explain
that I don't know we don't have to
explain everything do you know that
there's a growing movement that think
that the the space is fake space is fake
no I does any different than the Flat
Earth ruse little hashtag space is fake
hashtag space is fav it's people that
are so [ __ ] stupid the flat earthers
kicked him out oh my god
for real flat earthers kicked out the
spacious fake people space is fake is
their the the most skeptical so what
would be the upper atmosphere would be
the edge it's all [ __ ] it's all fake
and it's tied in some weird way to
religion
which is really interesting because even
the flat earth people there's a
tremendous amount of them that are
extremely religious and they they talk
about the firmament in the Bible in the
Bible and that this is uh this is what's
really going on is that they're trying
to keep us from the knowledge that God
has created this place is a very special
place right and so by pretending that
it's round they somehow or another are
controlling us we're thinking that we're
not exceptional we're not lucky space is
fake they're using a video from Ryan
Gosling's
movie he just made about in the
Armstrong there's a man on the moon
yeah let's be like this is look look
here's proof make everything fake
they're making a movie because literally
the way they made the movie is that's
evidence that it's fake because he's
wearing it I don't know if maybe this
person doesn't recognize that as being
Ryan Gosling right there hmm got a NASA
suit on
maybe it's just a troll account this is
how NASA makes everything this is the
video I was talking about guys now you
know it's all big act click on spaces
fake though I'm on the whole yeah but
click on it because there's a bunch of
I'm on that thread there's a tremendous
amount of people that literally believe
that space is not real Google video of
help Buzz Aldrin and how he deals with
the no Muniz that we never went to the
moon there's a video Buzz Aldrin
punching a guy yeah you see that guy i I
had dinner with that guy you did the guy
he punched yeah I was a firm believer
that we never went to the moon yeah you
know this is what happened I watched
that Fox documentary yeah the moon
conspiracy theory did we go and I was
like holy [ __ ] because it was on
television I was and this was 96 97 I
remember I went to work I told everybody
you got to see this documentary he's
crazy we never went to the moon and I
watched that one and I watched this
guy's what is his name bart sibrel oh
yeah so I had dinner with him he
absolutely believes that we never went
to the moon a hundred percent believes
it I don't know if he still believes it
I think he's like a cab driver or
something now he got he was involved in
the news or there's no local television
or something like that back where he's
from then he released a documentary
called the fun
anything happened on the way to the moon
and in his documentary one of the things
he did have is some really interesting
footage of the lunar module where it
looks like they're faking a shot of them
being really far out but then when they
remove this cover the covers from all
the windows that were inside the the
lunar not the lunar module what is the
one that the the orbiter it really looks
like they're in low-earth orbit and this
is like the the main thing pointing to
that like they couldn't get out of low
Earth orbit mm-hm
then there was also the fact that they
lost all of the telemetry data which was
the binary you know the ones and zeroes
it showed the position of the lunar
module at every stage there was a bunch
of different things the fact that no one
wanted especially Neil Armstrong he
became a recluse never wanted to talk
about it you go and watched the press
conference the press conference they
look very shady look like that
completely if it's not like that
he's Devery buddy he was a drunk for a
long time though he was he was very
depressed and had it when became an
alcoholic after the moon landing and the
idea is that the in conspiracy circles
form talking as them the idea is that he
got over it after a while needed to make
a living now talks about it constantly
but Neil Armstrong never did the thing
that's compelling is that there was
there were some there's some faking
going on if you look at Gemini was a
Gemini 15 Michael Collins there's an
image of Michael Collins when they were
testing some of the space walking stuff
and some of the some of the things they
would do to to to walk outside of a
spaceship they had them all strapped up
with cables and they're just
experimenting with these things they
took that photograph and then blacked
out the background probably some
overzealous PR agent and they were like
in the pool is it right here so what it
is is like so the first one is clearly
he's you know in a studio and they're
working on things and just trying to
understand how all this stuff works and
the second one they took the exact same
photo and just reversed it and blacked
out the background and they but it's
just yeah that does
mean that they didn't go to the moon
that just means that someone got a hold
of some photographs and faked it and
it's way more likely that there was more
of that going on then that people didn't
actually go to the moon right